retour aux urnes après la démission
d'angrinion de son siège à l'Assemblée
nationale les électeurs de la deuxième
circonscription ont du voter sans grande
surprise Jean-Noël Barrault l'emporte
aux élections législatives partielles
devant Maïté qui arrive bedouani de la
nupes déjà membre du gouvernement le
ministre 700 siège à sa suppléante Anne
bergence en pleine grève chez Total
énergie et Esso exon mobile près d'une
station-service sur trois connaît des
difficultés d'approvisionnement en
France une situation tendue également
dans les Yvelines situation compliquée
aussi dans tous les services
pédiatriques en cause une forte
propagation de bronchiolite chez les
enfants le mois de sensibilisation au
cancer du sein est lancée à l'occasion
d'Octobre Rose la première dame Brigitte
Macron s'est rendue aux trois arches à
Poissy ce lieu accompagne des personnes
atteintes par le cancer et l'émotion est
encore vive deux ans après l'assassinat
de Samuel Paty élu habitant professeur
et élève se sont réunis pour rendre
hommage aux assassiné par un terroriste
à Conflans-Sainte-Honorine durant les
championnats du monde de cyclisme sur
pistes au Vélodrome de Saint-Quentin en
Yvelines la France termine à la
troisième place execo au tableau des
médailles avec trois titres remportés à
23 ans livelinoise Mathilde gros
remporte son premier titre mondial à
domicile l'occasion de cet été avant
Paris 2024 eux ont enfin pris la mer
après plusieurs jours d'attentes en
raison du mauvais temps les 128 skippers
de la Route du Rhum sont partis en début
d'après-midi de Saint-Malo direction la
Guadeloupe parmi aux deux yvelinois le
rambolitain Louis Burton et le
versaillet
Eric Bellion dans l'actualité également
décembre marqués par une cyberattaque
d'envergure visant l'hôpital André
Mignot au Chesnay Rocancourt une cellule
de crise a été ouverte après les froid
leur était à l'Union et à l'apaisement
plus de 1000 personnes réunies en la
mémoire de Djibril ce jeune de 14 ans tu
es dans une rixe à Coignières la Marche
Blanche s'est déroulée entre le gymnase
du moulin à vent dieu du drame et
commune de Maurepas d'où était
originaire l'adolescent le département
revêt son manteau blanc placé en
vigilance orange neige et verglas par
Météo France environ 5 cm de neige sont
attendus les autorités invitent les
Yvelines à être prudents notamment sur
les routes et l'année s'achève presque
en beauté vous étiez 6000 à soutenir les
Bleus au vélo de Rome national de
Saint-Quentin en Yvelines et ce malgré
la défaite de la France en finale de
Coupe du monde face à l'Argentine au
cours d'un match à couper le souffle